[Musica]
e vorrei che nessuna bramante come
scritto vengo da finale emilia sono
cresciuto e nell'emilia che è un paese
qui vicino ho 38 anni proprio a finale
emilia ho avuto la fortuna insomma di
crescere in un paese molto tranquillo ea
volte noioso con anche un po la fretta
di voler vedere il resto del mondo un
altra fortuna è stata quella di avere
dei genitori che mi hanno dato
l'opportunità di viaggiare con loro e
attraverso questa fretta nel voler
vedere il resto del mondo
diciamo a 18 anni più o meno ho iniziato
a girare in bicicletta a 14 anni più o
meno giravo tale mila in bicicletta non
con biciclette da corsa anche in
lombardia dicevo a mia madre che andavo
a fare un giretto intorno al paese ed
era mio modo per fare esperienza sulla
strada fortunatamente sono cresciuto
sulla strada e diciamo anche oggi posso
dirlo fortunatamente i miei genitori non
mi hanno dato mai un supporto economico
per cui questo bisogno di vivere la
strada mi ha portato a 18 anni un po
fuori media italiana a uscire di casa
concludere quindi il liceo e iscrivermi
a lettere bologna da lì
diciamo ho avuto l'opportunità di
potermi scrivere con dei soldi che io
avevo guadagnato nei lavori estivi già a
partire dai 14 anni per cui da quello
dato ho dato modo di potermi mettere
alla prova pur non non in modo come dire
piacevole all'inizio perché il lavoro è
un impatto ha un impatto molto forte su
duramente su ognuno di noi per cui
questo in qualche modo mi ha dato
mi ha dato modo di vedere quale fosse la
realtà subito nonostante questo sono
uscito di casa su un altro l'università
pur comunque avendo bisogno di lavorare
il mio sogno era quello di diventare
professore di lettere all'università più
o meno è stato il periodo del 97 e non
avendo supporto anche solo morale dei
miei genitori mi sono reso conto quanto
la struttura insomma dell'ateneo
dell'università di bologna fosse
complicata anche solo dal punto di vista
amministrativo l'andare a rincorrere
sportelli fare ore di fila per cui
sempre fortunatamente che la fortuna è
una componente determinante credo per
ognuno di noi
[Musica]
internet era probabilmente alla sua
massima esplosione fine anni 90 e per me
diciamo che il veicolo principale è
sempre stato il come fare qualcosa come
faccio a uscire da una condizione che
non era per me favorevole sia studiare
sia lavorare per lavorare intendo anche
andare in bicicletta alle 5 del mattino
da fino all'emilia prendere un treno da
da san felice andare a bologna a
lavorare e non essere sicuri di poter
tornare a casa in tempo perché magari
facendo tardi al lavoro
avrei perso il treno e dormire magari in
stazione
cosa che non mi ha mai preoccupato
realmente però è sempre stato un rischio
questo mi dà la forza perché era la mia
unica opzione quindi provando e
lavorando o diciamo avuto la
determinazione di poter trovare poi un
lavoro fisso di ciò che mi piaceva in
quel momento era l'onda di internet
quindi anche già una città piccola come
bologna dava la possibilità a persone
che avevano una base di conoscenza di
questo tipo di lavorare io ho avuto la
determinazione di di essere assunto a
tempo indeterminato subito già a 21 anni
se non ricordo male è un po difficile
per me pensare al passato perché non è
una cosa che mi viene facile guardo
sempre un po quello che c'è da fare
da oggi in poi ad ogni modo molto
brevemente sono riuscito ad andare a
vivere a bologna ho iniziato a lavorare
ho dovuto lasciare l'università
perché non era poi la cosa non era la
mia nuova avventura come quella del
diciamo della mia gente pubblicitaria in
cui era andato a finire una cosa che mi
interessava molto a livello creativo
sicuramente dentro di me c'era già la
chiarezza di ciò che ero e cioè quello
nero
ero già sicuro di non essere una mente
matematica aime e quindi ho visto ho
potuto percepire questa cosa di me di
quanto la creatività invece mi venisse
più facile per cui le agenzie di
comunicazione agenzie pubblicitarie con
il web applicato quindi con nuovi mezzi
dove poter esprimere una base di
comunicazione quindi sul digitale
ho avuto diciamo la possibilità di
esprimere me stesso
questo l'ho fatto per più o meno un 10
15 anni
quindi cambiando spesso anche agenzie
nel momento in cui c'era c'era troppa
tranquillità nel momento in cui avevo
già imparato delle cose per me era già
necessario cambiare per cui per molti
anni ho cambiato moltissime agenzie sia
bologna un po milano parigi eccetera
perché ho fatto anche le periodi insomma
brevi di esperienze di questo tipo
tutto questo ovviamente con quella
fatica lì però anche con un senso di
avventura
noi siamo io sono cresciuto guardando
piero angela non tanto bim bum bam e
questo è stata sempre una fortuna perché
mi sono reso conto di quanto
fosse importante relazionarsi con un
mondo esterno
il mondo esterno di quark di piero
angela era del bambino africano con le
mosche negli occhi che questa l'immagine
insomma già negli anni ottanta girava
molto questo mi ha dato modo di
realizzare il fatto che noi non moriremo
di fame o per lo meno in quel periodo
per me era dato per scontato per cui non
avendo questo rischio
l'opportunità erano infinite sapendo che
non sarebbe mai successo questo negli
anni 90 per me tutto era possibile per
cui anche già cambiare lavoro non era un
rischio al limite sarei avrei cambiato
di nuovo lavoro comunque costruendo una
professionalità
fortunatamente ho avuto anche tantissime
esperienze positive di anche direttore
creativi molto molto importanti anche di
saccenza c francoforte eccetera abbiamo
anche vinto un leone a cannes per un
ambient media leone cannes della
pubblicità per cui da quello in qualche
modo sono riuscito ad avere un buon
carico di professionalità sia a livello
nazionale che internazionale con anche
diciamo clienti molto molto molto
interessante
di recente ho lavorato con un astronauta
canadese che si chiama chris hatfield è
stato il primo astronauta a registrare
un disco nello spazio
credo fosse 2011 2012 nel ricordo e
allora ho fatto un'esperienza di viaggio
con lui
lui mentre matematicamente scientifiche
anche ovviamente di base anche militare
e allora sfidandolo gli ho detto sì tu
ovviamente sei una un'autorità sei
comunque autorevole in canada ma
soprattutto anche a livello artistico
nel mondo per aver anche inciso space
oddity di david bowie e david bowie
quando senti la sua versione disse
questa qua assolutamente la versione più
bella però diciamo dal punto di vista
artistico
questo io nello stesso modo riesco ad
andare nello spazio ovviamente
ironicamente wiston churchill diciamo
tirato fuori questa citazione perché è
quella che in qualche modo in una
società dove l'economia sembra la cosa
più importante
una frase di questo tipo mi rincuora
perché nel momento in cui l'inghilterra
prima dell'intervento degli stati uniti
nella seconda guerra mondiale
l'inghilterra stava subendo gli eventi
bombardamenti da dalla diciamo dai
nazisti dall'asse un giornalista gli
chiese perché non perché non tagli il
budget per le per le arti insomma le
disse ma allora perché stiamo
combattendo noi
in effetti l'art
la parte artistica la parte creativa di
noi esseri umani è probabilmente uno
degli elementi che porta
diciamo alimenta la nostra cultura
quindi ritornando sul sul su chris apcom
sulla strana uta il sì anch'io riesco
andare nello spazio
ovviamente in modo giocoso per dirgli
anche la creatività in qualche modo può
raccontarti qualcosa che non senti che
non è scientificamente
insomma vissuto questo qua uno scatto
fatto a medicina è un altro paese dove
io ho vissuto poi c'è stato un altro
un altro fatto abbastanza importante per
me è che è stato la nascita di mio
figlio
dopo tanti anni ovviamente nella
pubblicità ho voluto testare la vita
tranquilla comprandomi casa in campagna
con gli animali però per me era troppo
tranquilla come cosa ho avuto una grande
fonte di ispirazione in quel periodo si
parla del 2009 2008 2009 grazie a
terzani leggendo molto terzani lui ha
avuto un cambio di vita molto forte
più o meno 30 31 anni immagino che molti
di voi conosceranno la storia da
impiegato dell'olivetti divenne poi
giornalista di del spiegel e così iniziò
la sua avventura
io più o meno in quel periodo avevo 31
anni e mio figlio è nato in quel periodo
lì
e proprio in quel periodo ho ricevuto
una macchina fotografica come regalo per
me è stato ovviamente la miccia che ha
fatto esplodere
insomma quello che fosse diciamo la mia
determinazione nel non perdere più tempo
vivere in una casa tranquilla con un
lavoro tra con un lavoro sicuro per me
non era abbastanza guardando la nostra
vita in una una timeline sapendo di non
rischiare niente perché non siamo in un
paese africano o del bangladesh o sotto
le bombe perché non giocarsela perché
non tentare tutto per cui nel momento in
cui diventando padre
diciamo il segmento temporale dedicato a
me stesso si è notevolmente accorciato
ho capito che solo in quel lasso di
tempo così stretto dovevo fare tutto
quello che non avevo fatto prima
negli anni prima
ho cercato sempre di applicare la
creatività colacone ovviamente le regole
di comunicazione che ho imparato durante
il decennio prima ho cambiato tantissimi
lavori
ho cercato di andare oltre quelli che
sono diciamo le regole o i modelli
esistenti vedi l'esempio del cercarsi da
lavorare con il curriculum
avete presente il curriculum europeo il
formato europeo quel doc tutto sformato
il mio ultimo curriculum di dire 56 anni
fa invece era un infografica cosa
difficilmente comprensibile per la
maggior parte delle aziende
a me non è mai interessato andarmi a
cercare la maggior parte delle aziende
io ho sempre puntato su se c'è un
azienda a cui interessa questa cosa è la
mia azienda e l'azienda per cui lavorare
e questo è stata insomma già cercando di
giocare anche con i quark od eccetera
poi fortunatamente è arrivato instagram
sono arrivate social media di cui con
cui già lavoravo da qualche anno
come direttore creativo in un'agenzia di
bologna e per cui ha iniziato grazie a
quella macchina fotografica regalata al
giorno della nascita di mio figlio ho
iniziato a studiare questa nuova
opportunità la fotografia attraverso il
telefono sicuramente qualcuno di voi
sarà appassionata di fotografia si
ricorderà quanto cartier bresson abbia
cambiato il mondo della fotografia con
delle macchine con la laica fu
mentalmente venne osteggiato all'inizio
perché era uno era uno strumento nuovo
quindi strumento nuovo significa
sicuramente bassa qualità
il telefono la stessa cosa forte di
questo e grazie ovviamente alle
competenze legate alla comunicazione ho
intravisto diciamo un'opportunità come
fare per quel famoso come fare per nel
cambiare le regole anche in questo senso
per cui ho iniziato a studiare molto lo
strumento ovviamente il device insieme
alle regole fotografiche cosa che non è
stata semplicissima all'inizio perché mi
trovavo a usare uno a usare l'altro non
capire la profondità con uno con l'altro
e la cosa ovviamente mi mandava in crisi
ad ogni modo
sta di fatto che sono a oggi sono il
primo fotografo italiano su instagram
grazie anche a tante pubblicazioni che
sono avvenute più o meno nel 2013 2014
soprattutto negli stati uniti cosa non
possibile qua in italia perché
probabilmente non troppo oltre le regole
di quel momento quindi forbes o vogue
tanti altri post eccetera e da lì è
partito ovviamente un tipo di lavoro
quindi lavorare con la fotografia
insieme ai social media
da lì ovviamente nel corso degli ultimi
3 4 anni ho iniziato a sviluppare molti
progetti identificando molto la mia
fotografia con un'estetica per cui con
varie esperienze di viaggio più o meno
tutto il mondo e li fortunatamente mi
sono reso conto di quanto il mio sogno
da bambino di viaggiare si fosse
realizzato non avendo avuto la
possibilità economica nel fare dei
viaggi per divertimento con qualche anno
in più sono riuscito a viaggiare per
lavoro dove per me viaggiare non è solo
il viaggiare per divertimento ma è
l'esperienza di viaggio
un'altra cosa importante è giusto minuto
nel momento in cui arrivi ad avere molte
centinaia di migliaia di persone che
seguono il tuo lavoro non voglio chemali
follower ma sono persone si arriva ad
avere una responsabilità anche sociale
la responsabilità è quella di comunicare
costantemente con delle nel mio caso con
le immagini ma anche con con parole
quindi raccontare storie di lo
storytelling famoso per cui ad un certo
punto mi sono relazionato con delle il
mio network di persone che nel corso
degli anni mi sono creato i
professionisti e non per cui abbiamo
dato abbiamo avviato un progetto
territoriale che si chiama what italease
per due motivi il primo perché non
conoscevo l'italia dal punto di vista
digitale
ho viaggiato tutta l'italia ma non
conoscevo quali persone sul digitale e
sui canali social ci fossero
perché mi sono sempre relazionato con
gli stati uniti fondamentalmente per
questioni di lavoro per cui abbiamo
avviato questo progetto editoriale che
si chiama italease un po in contrasto
diciamo con il famoso italia.it e altre
attività istituzionali di poco riso con
risultati davvero scarsi e da lì è
partito questo progetto editoriale che
adesso conta anche lì diciamo molte
persone che seguono insomma questa
attività con l'intento ovviamente come
secondo obiettivo quello di raccontare
il territorio
diciamo il micro territorio non l'italia
nella sua interezza non l'italia delle
cartoline non l'italia mainstream e nel
corso di questi tre anni in più o meno
di attività abbiamo raccontato persone
come una tedesca che da non so 50 anni
60 anni vive a napoli di quanto fosse
stato per lei difficile vista la sua
cultura relazionarsi con una città così
diversa storie anche di persone che sia
un giovane o anziani non importa da
quello abbiamo ovviamente avuto
l'opportunità di relazionarci con il
territorio con anche istituzioni
territoriali per cui la liguria la città
di napoli la città di bologna anche
adesso con la toscana la regione toscana
ma anche i territori toscani i parchi
regionali cosa paradossale perché
l'italia non è vista come a livello
turistico come diceva tiziana come
un'entità unica come un'offerta unica
ogni piccolo territorio in qualche modo
non si relaziona con quello di fianco e
questo l'abbiamo scoperto un po diciamo
sulla nostra pelle lavorando proprio con
territori di questo tipo ed è cosa che
continueremo fare io vi lascio qua
grazie per l'attenzione
[Applauso]